hey what's up guys my name is a cha know
and recently I've been hearing that a
lot of you want to watch the game
programming series offline so in other
words you want download links to be able
to download all the episodes of game
programming as they come out to either
you know put put them on your iPad or
something and watch them in the car or
something when you're on a massive road
trip or otherwise just have them offline
maybe your internet connection isn't
great so you can go to your friend's
place and download it I've been hearing
a lot of that recently so I decided to
do something about it now what you want
to do to get these offline videos
essentially is good at the China calm
that's my website right so once you've
done that you're going to want to
register if you haven't already or login
if you're or if you already have an
account once you do that that's very
important you actually make an account
that you want to keep because once you
do that once you are logged in you want
to hit up game programming ok and the
links to all of this will be in the
description so do not worry you do need
you do need a hat actually have a user
account for this so once you see this
game programming page you want to click
on in game programming episodes offline
massive thing you cannot miss it and
once you click on that you will be taken
to a page eventually the server is a bit
slow i'm thinking of switching to
dedicated hosting so you'll see this
page and it will basically outline now
it does cost ten dollars alright and
that is mainly because of the fact that
while hosting hosting all these files is
um is not cheap but the the idea is that
what you do is you purchase this for ten
dollars it gets tied to your account
which means that whenever i release new
episode it will automatically be updated
so it's not like you're buying the
current release like it's kind of like
it's almost like a like a like a
minecraft logic kind of thing right you
buy the game but you get every update as
it comes out well same thing here right
you buy the series and you get every
single episode so once you do buy it and
you can just hit add to cart you can pay
through paypal that's the only method um
and that I'm accepting right now one
once you do all of that you will if you
go back to the game programming page
once you've bought it you will see her
this write a list of episodes every
single episode all right there's one
threw 96 right now now there will also
be a zip file of all of them they might
be in volume so like episode 1 to 25 and
you can actually download every episode
it just in one go all right and then you
can actually in a nice mp4 format as
well so you'll be able to UM put them on
your iPad or any other Apple device
because I know that there are like the
conversion for them isn't isn't great
basically but they're in a very good
format they are in 1080p so they burned
the best format that they can be and you
can actually watch them online as well
not sure why what again these are all
free on YouTube so this is more like a
convenience kind of if you want to have
the episodes downloadable thing um and
yeah so you can watch them online here
right pretty standard stuff or of course
the idea is to save them so you can
right click on any one of these videos
hit Save Link As and then you'll
actually be able to well save it and it
will download as you can see over here
all right so that's pretty much it now
all the episodes are here and as I
released new I'll just update into this
list and this purchase does get tied to
your account so make sure again that you
do actually make an account that you
want to use I don't know why you would
just make a fake account or something
but um that's probably an important
thing to consider yes but apart from
that hopefully you know if this goes
well as well and hopefully you know I
think it will and a lot of other a bunch
of people probably buy it if you guys do
as well don't forget that um this does
actually support me obviously because a
lot of people have also been asking me
if they can donate or something I I
really don't like taking donations just
for the hell of it you might have
noticed that I don't do this the reason
is I kind of like I understand that I'm
helping a lot of people and you guys
want to kind of give back to me but I
just I don't like receiving money for
something that I'm doing for free yeah
so this is a way to to give to me i
guess and and keep me i'm not feeling
guilty and
way but also the most of the proceeds
from this will actually go to hosting to
dedicated hosting essentially dedicated
web hosting because this website is very
slow because of course there's a bunch
of database stuff happening here as well
as all of you guys are on this like this
page is getting like thousands of hits
per day so it's not great especially the
forums so um that's what that's one of
the things that hopefully will be coming
very very soon so if you guys do enjoy
my game programming series you want to
support me as well as you want these
wonderful offline files in 1080p that
you can put on to any mobile device
device or just watch it on your computer
then feel free to to head over the
janitor come for such games of all such
game programming not game development
and go ahead and buy that so thanks for
watching guys there should be a lot more
episodes coming shortly i'm finishing up
a unit for the year and i'll see you
guys next time goodbye